[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show
i'm your host paul and even though i
live in the uk you know i had to break
down these new trailers that just popped
out at the super bowl like janet
jackson's nipple
atopical it kicked off with a look at
godzilla versus kong
then the snyder cut before winging it
into falcon in the winter soldier
which gave away a lot of story beats
this is nacho average trailer talk
and there will be heavy spoilers here as
well as some terrible punts
hey punts now if you enjoy the video
please drop a thumbs up
and don't forget to subscribe for
breakdowns like this each and every day
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into the super bowl
trailers
okay so i'm not gonna lie when i saw the
schneider cup footage announcement
i went in a tight end but ended up
coming out a wide receiver in my pants
by the way if you want to skip ahead to
any of the trailer breakdowns
the time codes will be below in both the
video chapters and descriptions
or just skip the entire video because
it's going to be crap but fittingly with
this super bowl
zach released a clip on his vero account
of victor stone playing football
and scoring a touchdown we know from the
film that this is the big game that he
wished his father to be at
but because of work he didn't show up
his mother was there in the crowd
cheering him on
but when they got in the car tempers
flared and vic got angry that his father
put his work before him
and he and his mother had an argument
this actually caused the accident that
killed her
and rendered him in critical condition
from here his dad turned him into a half
man half lean green grilling machine and
thus this
football moment ties in heavily with his
origin story
it's the great triumph that his father
should have been there for
and his dad of course blames himself for
what went on
whilst victor blames himself for causing
his mother's death
adding a lot of complexity to their
relationship
we also know that a brand new trailer
will be released on the 14th of february
at 9 15 am pst which will potentially
have
a new look at the joker and a lot more
so cancel your valentine's plans
i've told my wife she's divorced and yes
guys
we're gonna be doing a big breakdown
next up is godzilla versus kong
which though quite small in terms of
what was shown
still left a big impression i found it
quite funny that the japanese one
actually showed godzilla getting some
licks in
whilst in the western one it was pretty
much all kong
i'm guessing that warner brothers know
japan loves godzilla as he took a huge
focus in this one
and most of the new shots primarily
center around him
now the first new bit of footage was the
navy attacking him with missiles
which then caused him to submerge we now
know that he's going to be going into
the fight straight away
and approaching kung from the water but
the navy will be doing all that they can
to stop him early on
which will then probably escalate to the
fight between kong and godzilla
the second clip added showed a lot more
friends sarah zara
who is ishiro's son dr sarah zara in
general has been a staple of godzilla
movies
and his father ishiro was of course a
big part in the 2014 film
as well as king of the monsters now due
to one of the shots in the trailer
it has been theorized that he is
actually the person who was brought on
board to build mechagodzilla
in it we could see him standing in front
of a control panel
with an outline of the mechanical
monster on one of the screens
and therefore we can take it that he's
the one controlling the beast according
to the rumors on the film
he has been hired by apex the villains
of the movie
and will be trying to avenge his father
who he believes was killed by the titans
making for quite an interesting dynamic
i've already made a full trailer
breakdown which goes into a lot more
depth on the role of mechagodzilla
which i will link at the end if you want
to see it you also get a couple more
lines from rebecca hall's character
irene andrews
in which he says the myths are real
there was a war and they're the last
ones standing
we know from leaks in the movie that the
film will discuss the battle between the
kungs and gajira
that happened millennia ago since then
they've all been pretty much wiped out
other than these two
but these guys yeah they've still
remained mortal enemies
the inhabitants of skull island knew the
day was coming when godzilla would face
off against kong
and even though they were proper annoyed
that the movie kept getting delayed
they started to prepare for their main
man and made a giant axe
this is the one that we see being used
in the trailer and apparently it's made
from a giant tree with the blade being
one of the gojira dorsal fins
we don't know if this is godzilla or his
granddad's
but what a bloody smack in the mouth
that'll be i think there's a couple more
shots in hong kong
and overall it just hypes up the fight a
bit more and shows
how desperate that the humans are yay
more human drama in a monster movie
now finally is the falcon and winter
soldier trailer
or maybe even the spring soldier as the
new series will be released weekly
starting from the 19th of march
so we have the snyder cut dropping on
the 18th before this
meaning that it's going to be a busy
week in the kevin's spoilers household
a lot of the scenes in the trailer have
been seen in the brighter one including
the memorial for the fallen sokovia
victims
which zemo stands in front of i don't
want to just rehash all the ground with
our breakdown
as we have a lot to get through so if
you want to know more about the
ins and outs of this trailer then make
sure you check out our breakdown of the
original one which will be linked at the
end
however we do get a fair bit of new info
and
open on what i think is a debriefing
this shows that sam and bucky are now
working alongside the government once
more
as it was saw that they were still in
trouble for the events of civil war
but it does seem like they're back in
the good books now it is thought that
because the government created the ip of
captain america
that they own the rights to him and that
sam has to hand over the shield in order
to make them stop chasing the pair
they then give the two a job which is
why this looks like a formal setting for
them to be in
and they're just keeping a watchful eye
on them as they know they're bad boys
and could go
rogue at any time that's luds the person
carrying out the debris thing says
why does sam aggravate you and at the
end of the trailer there's quite a funny
bit where
they they do just stare at each other it
reminds me of me and the wife who
let's just say is not happy that i'm
spending so much time on youtube
but we're in lockdown so what you're
gonna do
leave me pathetic she wouldn't leave me
she's gone now it looks like the two are
sort of in a staring contest at the end
but
they're clearly just trying to be as
annoying as possible for the woman in
the debriefing
so that they can escape kind of get the
feeling that this might actually be a
plan to find out what's really going on
at this place
and that they'll bust out of this not
long after but let me know if you
disagree
or think anything else we then cut to
the titles
and get another look at mad rapport this
fictional asian country from the marvel
universe
is heavily tied to wolverine and this is
why many think that the character will
be popping up the mcu
a lot sooner than you thought when i say
things you missed in the title as well
i'm talking about you specifically yeah
you didn't think wolverine was coming at
all did you you idiot
now evan peters popping up at the end of
one division did show that the marvel
universe looks to be going that way
but for now i don't know for definite
but you
do so so can you tell me here please i'm
inspired by singapore this location was
leaked when flags were spotted on set
for the series
and it looks like the pair will be
investigating crime in the area
what's what's quite good about madrapa
is that there's a sort of dichotomy to
it
and the city is actually divided up into
two sections
this includes high town and low town
both of which are as bad as each other
but hightown is sort of a white-collar
crime area that the elites reside in
whereas low-town is the lowest of the
low and it's just
a bad place to be now the duality of
this is also reflected in both sam and
bucky
as the pair have their own aspects and
are not really held in high regards
but as we know things aren't as they
seem with them
thus this feels like the perfect mission
for them to take part in
and i can actually see them splitting up
and going through the city from top to
bottom
shortly after we see zemo's mask which
is now in line with the character's look
in the comics
zemo seems to be going around
terrorizing people and it is possible
that after this snap he managed to
escape the confines of his jail
and started to wreak havoc on the world
he says that superheroes can't be
allowed to exist
and that he has no intention to leave
his work unfinished
meaning that he's probably gonna try and
kill everyone all over again
yay now i don't really feel like he's
gonna be the full villain in this
i actually think that he might end up
working with sam and bucky at one point
in the original trailer we did see bucky
unloaded a gun in front of him
and apparently the buckster goes to zemo
who then utters the mind control words
to him
showing that he's no longer under his
control bucky empties the gun
and they then take him in we also get a
bit more of a look at black smasher who
has now been confirmed to be the villain
last video i had a lot of people getting
annoyed at me and saying that it was the
red hulk that they were
actually working for and that i didn't
know what i was talking about but
it has indeed been confirmed to be them
in the comics
flag smasher is very much the opposite
to captain america
and they want to basically bring down
the idea of patriotism
in order to allow people to operate of
their own free will
instead of feeling like they have to
serve a country flag smasher has also
been gender swapped
and i'm wondering if they've had any
enhancements as they easily beat bucky
up who gets mocked by sam at one point
we then see what looks like the ceremony
in which captain america will be picked
by the us government
as we know from the behind the scenes
looks this will be why
russell is us agent and sam has to hand
over the shield
bucky doesn't look too happy and we then
cut to sam throwing the shield
which metaphorically symbolizes that he
might have to give it away
we know from far from home that captain
america is thought to be dead
and thus sam can't really say that he is
meant to be the next in line
as it would give away that his best
mates now living at the old people's
home
and partying like it's his last day on
earth which
it might it might well be at that age
sam looks really upset
and it's also possible that this is a
memorial service to captain america
he obviously knows the truth of the
matter and is likely having to lie
in order to make it so that his friend
can have some peace a big
interesting part of the trailer is that
we get our first look at sharon carter
who once more is played by emily vancamp
due to info released on the project we
know that she's now in
outlaw after breaking the sokovia
accords and that she may have even been
on the run for seven years
i kind of feel like she might sort of be
a love interest to the pair
and that they'll not only be getting
steve's sloppy seconds
but also his niece which is a double
whammy
she's clearly able to hold her own and
we see her kicking all kinds of butts in
the trailer
so yeah i'm very hyped to see her back
as she she's a good character that in
the comics
not in the movies that much but
definitely in the comics now we also see
a couple more shots
and tell you what stop typing that in
the comments right now saying that she's
your favorite character i'm sorry i
didn't mean it
now we also see a couple more shots of
mad rapper namely the club scene in
which falcon and bucky are going to meet
a contact
we get some more aerial combat shots
against hydra
and there's also a better look at the
football ceremony for the new captain
america
which we know will be riffing on the
star spangled man with a plan from the
first movie
you also end up with sam back on the
plane using his wings as a shield
whilst soldiers fire upon him these are
likely hydra agents
and i kind of feel like this follows on
from the big fight across
what may or may not be the grand canyon
or it could set it up
now sam then picks up and throws the
shield again and though many think that
he's fighting with it as his weapon
i actually think that this is him going
toe to toe with us agent
who in the comics was a villain when he
first came on the scene
i feel like he will be helping flag
smasher to carry out the attacks
and then we'll be going in to stop them
similar to mysterio
and that our two heroes will uncover
this plot the trailer then ramps up to a
couple of big action scenes
and we then cut to sam and bucky getting
lost in each other's eyes
anyway i absolutely love this first look
and from the day we now know that one
division will end
and we'll get a two week break before
going into this which likely means that
we'll have a two week break when it
finishes
and then going to loki after loki we get
what if
and after that it's hawkeye i think so
there's plenty of things to look forward
to in 2021
anyway those are the trailers and i'd of
course love to hear your thoughts on
them
and if there's anything we missed make
sure you comment below and let me know
and as a thank you for interacting with
the video you'll be entered into a prize
from the 28th of february in which we're
giving away three copies of the marvel
phase 3 4k box set to our subscribers
all you have to do to begin with the
chance of winning is like the video make
sure you subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment below with your
thoughts on the trailers
the winners of last month's competition
are on screen right now so that's you
then message me on twitter at
heavyspoilers
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our latest
breakdown of one division which will be
linked on screen right now
we went over the entire episode top to
bottom and pointed out all the cool
little easter eggs in it
so it's definitely worth checking out if
you want to know more without the way
thank you for sending through the video
i mean paul i'll see you next time take
care peace